[Music]
all right so I want to shift a little
bit to foreign policy because I think
that's sort of one of your one of your
would you say that's one of your main
strengths love my my claim to fame was
kind of terrorism and stuff like this
but but really deep Donna I'm a strategy
wonk
yeah grand strategy is my thing okay so
we'll talk we'll talk in the lens of
strategy then so as we're taping this
right now I mentioned earlier it's gonna
it's gonna sit on the shelf for a couple
days so I don't want to get too lost in
anything that happened today but at the
moment it's a little upside down in
Syria you know there might have been
strikes already from when we're taping
this hungry just had elections in your
Wikipedia that I referenced earlier it
says you worked for the guy who just won
you apparently you never worked for him
you know with his party I wasn't Victor
lorta bonds advisor yeah which is what
it says on Wikipedia at least what's
your general thoughts on foreign policy
strategy like what is a sensible policy
and and his Trump applying that view
first things first
the great irony of our nation is that we
are the most powerful nation the world
has ever seen and until recently we have
been the dumbest and most a strategic I
mean we haven't done we haven't thought
or acted strategically since about 1989
November the 9th with a burning wall
fell and and this is you know how have
we acted what would you say that since
then it's just 90s was just this kind of
confused what is national security about
there lurching for the snooze button
just who are the threat is it China is a
weapons of mass destruction is that you
can Slavic it was just a mess and then
we had 2001 and 9/11 and we had just
neocon disasters it's not an accident
these guys were former Trotskyites
because they're so naive the way they
look at the world that we're going to
create democracy at the end of a gun
barrel in a country with 36 languages
that defeat Alexander the Great and the
British Empire and the Soviets it
couldn't be stupider if you tried so you
know we've done some very very foolish
things because we haven't stuck to the
basic
strategy at the end of the day is about
one thing it's about prioritization
based upon interests right you've got to
say some things are more important than
others and guess what some countries are
more important than others and in a
postmodern secular world you're not
allowed or no all countries or Vanuatu
is important networking wrong it's not
that everyone loved the people Vanuatu
but no it's not a geostrategic import to
the country of America so number one we
have to prioritize and I think this
administration I doff my cap to Nadia
shad low HR McMasters deputy
she held the pen in the meetings that I
was in on the new national security
strategy of America and I'd tell you
David it is the first document of that
name in 30 years that deserves the name
national security strategy every
administration has them this is the
first one that says this is what we
stand for these are our values these are
our friends these are our enemies and
this is what we're going to prioritize
prior to that it was laundry lists of
well we're gonna have to Front Wars
we're gonna save the whales and you know
no so you have to prioritize and finally
this administration is about America
first
we are not isolationist nor are we
interventionist this is really annoys me
that if you're a conservative for 20
years you were given two options button
a invade other people's countries and
occupy them mm-hmm
button B B you know around Easter and
close the you know the curtains on the
Pacific and the Atlantic and say we
don't care about anybody else well guess
what it's the most powerful nation in
the world there is a large palette of
options - there's got to be something in
the middle area it's about being smart
and it's about our interests and it to
summarize the president's approach this
isn't official but I like it we have
numerous former generals an active
generals from the marine corps of the
highest level of the administration
showed the droid Chiefs chief of staff
secretary defense an interesting thing
is they all come from the same Marine
Corps division not just a Marine Corps
the same division and that division has
a motto no better friend no worse enemy
that's America first
so when you see someone like John Bolton
being now part of the cabinet and if you
were to look on you know not that you
can get truth out of Twitter but the day
it was happening you know everybody's
saying this is gonna start World War
three and but you know just the general
hysterics and now John Bolton is
definitely suspect more of a neocon than
you're comfortable with is that I don't
think it's fair to call him a neocon and
I don't think he's ideologically driven
if you watch the videos that he you know
we recorded of his speeches 20 years ago
he was sounding very much like Trump
we're American we have interest you want
to work with us fine if you don't
there's a problem so and I think it's
very telling that within 40 minutes of
the president's tweet about John coming
on board massive Alton gave an interview
on Fox and they asked him about what he
gonna be like as a national security
adviser and he gave a very interesting
answer he quoted Dean Acheson and the
the the doyen of foreign policy in
America and I don't if his true story
but John said Dean Acheson was once once
asked how do you have such a good
relationship with the president who
serve and Dean Acheson said well it's
very easy we may disagree on policy
issues but at the end of the day I never
forget who was elected president and it
wasn't me that's a John Bolton 2.0 he
understands that unlike his predecessor
HR McMaster he's not there to lecture
the President or foist
his version of what you should do on to
the commander-in-chief he's there to be
an honest broker and provide a palette
of options because guess who gets to
decide the person who was elected
president so I am very excited about
John I'm as excited about Mike Pompeo
coming from the CIA to the State
Department
the we are in very good hands David so
how do you make sure if it's between the
pure isolationists and yeah and the
neo-cons are some writing something like
the nation builders something like that
how do you make sure that not everything
that you do outside of our borders
becomes something much bigger I mean
look we're still at war in Afghanistan I
don't think anyone knows why I mean can
you can you tell me why we're at war in
Afghanistan can anyone tell you why why
we went why we went to
pianist on in October one is the only
reason we should be there today
nothing's changed okay the idea that
girls go to school I love it I get it
and that people can listen to music
freely and the Taliban won't execute you
my parents lived under communism like my
father suffered under fascism he
protected his fellow Jewish classmates
during the occupation of Budapest I get
it I don't like those kinds of systems
but there's only one reason we were
there to make sure that that piece of
land mass would never ever again be used
to execute mass casualty attacks in
Manhattan in Washington or in a field in
Pennsylvania
end of story it's not about building a
Ring Road around Kabul they're not even
the Soviets could finish it's all about
building hospitals I'm sorry you never
make the ideal the enemy of the good
what the president does is he looks at
things as questions of possibility you
cannot be a massively successful realtor
in the toughest market in new you are in
the world which is New York real estate
if you have a filter that distorts
reality I mean either this square
footage is worth X or it's not worth X
according to the market and that's how
he approaches these issues so
Afghanistan it's only important to make
sure bad guys don't use it again to kill
Americans in America so yeah so you
would say or at least if you were if you
had to guesstimate basically what he
believes you would say that he believes
that still keeping us there at the
moment is still accomplishing yeah oh I
don't have to guesstimate on you though
yeah so you believe that as well because
it just seems unclear that he will he
will never I tell you right this 71 year
old man who is now the most powerful man
in the world will never ever ever buy
into a nation-building scenario anywhere
outside of the United States not
happening for the next seven years
end of story and the idea that you have
my followers on Twitter tearing their
hair out that bolton's going to have us
invade Syria guys get a grip on reality
and stop talking about crisis actors and
tinfoil hat garbage it's not gonna
happen while the president's the
president well that I tweeted something
to that effect the day of the Bolton
thing because it also reminds me that
people don't understand basic
deterrence that you have to bring in
people that you know talk a big game so
that per North Korea's hello yeah right
the man who was going to take us to war
what did he do I think the success in
North Korea today has in a large part
being part have been thanks to his
tweets because that's how you deal with
dictators you make fun of them they hate
that
and then you ridicule them right and
then you do what you scared them
oh and lo and behold they want to
negotiate for the first time in 65 years
well isn't that interesting do you think
there's any chance he would ever give up
his nukes about three percent because at
that point what leverage does he ever
left right so that well you still think
it's worth having the talks to figure
out what we can absolutely because
what's happened for the last twenty five
years
escalation escalation escalation II we
we have given into nuclear blackmail
since Bill Clinton so yeah we have to at
the end of the day we have to remember
1953 was not a peace treaty 1953 in
Korea was a ceasefire in an armistice
mhm that is actually a war that's just
simply been frozen for 65 years would be
nice to have a little bit of a peace
treaty or something yeah how much of
what's happening in the world right now
do you you must be thrilled I assume
with everything going on at the UN that
Haley has basically walked in there and
John Bolton 2.0 yeah yeah I mean she
strikes me as I almost wonder did Trump
really know what he was getting with
Holly yeah did anyone think anybody did
yeah we're way did you know her at all
where do you think that that come I
don't know as a friend she found herself
she found herself and more power to it
what what usefulness do you see in the
UN at this point because it seems like
truly it seems like the most corrupt
should be pushed into the river I mean
really well the building's basically
other now they're gonna quote that and
go you see he was calling for her I'm
right I think to be knocked into the
room look the idea was a good idea in
1945 in San Francisco that let's have an
organization that stops us from killing
60 men
in people again but when you lock in
dictatorships like China and Russia in
to the Security Council with veto power
and then you create this this empire of
un organizations I mean it has there
been a year in the last 20 years that we
haven't seen a UN scandal whether it's
money for oil whether it's UN troops
raping children in Africa have we seen
it one year without un scandal I don't
think so so try and reform it if you
can't question the validity of what it
does forget I'm not talking about you
know the the the the children's rights
organizations and food food security I'm
talking about its main mission which is
stability and safety it's failed
abysmally yeah what do you make of the
endless obsession with Israel that
something like 47 of the last 51
resolutions are against Israel usually
voted on by countries I'm sorry but that
alone is a reason to dissolve the UN I
mean what a lack of moral compass
what an utter bankruptcy of the morality
that there are nations in the world that
actually still have slavery going on
slavery where we're basic human rights
for individuals are not guaranteed based
upon sex based upon lifestyle choices
and you're going to lambast Israel the
only real democracy in the Middle East
yeah i think i think you know i mean
that that in and of itself is reason
enough to question the nature of the UN
so is the u.s. sort of in an odd
position where it's like if we don't do
anything nothing can get done sort of
and that that then puts us endlessly in
these Quagmire's or at least in these
positions where we can either watch the
world burn or get involved in things
where we may end up adding to the
burning in the first place like for
example you know with Russia going into
Crimea you know they gave up their
weapons right they gave up the weapons
they said all right NATO's gonna take
care of us but what that really means is
the United States is gonna take care of
you and I'm not saying we should have
gone in
and done anything there but that we're
in this endless situation now where it
is either us there there is no
international fighting but but again
very super careful not to get caught in
a binary dichotomy you can absolutely
say a world without American leadership
is a more dangerous world because it was
for the last eight years look I mean we
had a government that actually said
we're going to lead from behind which is
an oxymoron you cannot lead from behind
we're going to have strategic patience
which means we do nothing and allow
others to act what happened you name it
from China building fake military bases
on fake islands to Isis to Russia
invading it was just a disaster
Egypt we back the guy the other guys
then we back the so yeah to say that a
world learn American leadership is is
more dangerous is true but that doesn't
mean that we have to fix everybody's
problem and that's that's where smart
strategy comes in where you say but we
have a moral duty to espouse certain
values but that doesn't mean we are
responsible for all human beings because
because the American Revolution says the
opposite each nation is responsible the
citizens are responsible if you don't
like your system do something about it
because guess what we did against the
most powerful empire in the world so
again it's about finding that the happy
medium in the middle and being smart
about it
and again without being callous being
realistic right there are trosset e's
everywhere from Rwanda to Yugoslavia
bara American taxpayer is gonna pay for
fixing all of them are we responsible
are they responsible for what's
happening in their country sure are the
timezone we could perhaps help them
uh-huh but it's a balance like to
balance all right so let's shift back to
your book yeah so defeating jihad it
seems to me that the the main sort of
narrative on this is not that we can
defeat it but we should live with it
that there's a degree of it with which
we should just live which is don't carry
knives in London
and it's you know we're gonna put up
more barricades so the trucks can't be
driven into buildings or into shopping
centers or just down the street and
killing people that we can't really
defeat this ideology we just have to
manage it yeah I suspect you do not
agree with that premise no because we've
defeated ideologies before you can't
look Vera idiot to run around with you
know swastika armbands today I get it so
Nazism hasn't disappeared but we have
made it so enough Emma that if you walk
down the street with a Nazi flag you
will be rejected by society instantly
the same thing with the KKK right sadly
not with Che Guevara for the hammer and
sickle right right right but but there
are ways to defeat ideologies or to put
them in a box where they're laughable
and and everybody
shuns them we have to do the same thing
with jihadism this is my argument this
is the conclusion of the book we have to
be as effective in dealing in amaizing
the message of Gia because very simply
put killing jihadis is great but at the
end of the day body-bags is a metric not
a good metric it didn't work in Vietnam
doesn't work today because guess what if
you've got a recruiting pool that's
massive that is recruit new jihadis so
what's your victory condition your
victory condition is when the life style
of jihad is no longer sexy from Brussels
to San Bernardino how do you do that you
make a laughingstock you discredit that
value system not a slimy no white
skinned Catholic isn't gonna do it right
but we helped President Sisi
we helped King Abdullah of Jordan will
help MBS in Saudi Arabia with MBS the
historic things he said I mean massive
about Israel in just the last few weeks
yeah that's how we win because sooner or
later enough people say those guys are
losers that's how we win well but you
only do that if you get to talk about it
truthfully you've got to be able to talk
about the Quran or jihad means the
history of the religion because if you
can't talk about it honestly you never
going to treat it accurately yeah we're
not very good at that though well thanks
I political correctness right I mean
imagine if you know you're your doctor
and you've got a patient that comes in
with your third stage
you know lymphoma but your hospital
administrator because it's a scary word
is bad the use of the word cancer you
can't say it right it's just not allowed
yeah and then you have to tell the
patient what well you know you're
dehydrated go home drink some water and
take some aspirin what happens your
patient they die it's the same thing if
you can't diagnose a geostrategic
issue accurately however much money you
throw at it you will not solve the
problem so are you concerned at all that
just even if it's purely because of the
way the media frames things that perhaps
Trump is not the right person to lead
the fight against this that for whatever
whatever he's gonna say about jihad or
radical Islamic terrorism or the rest
that even if he said everything the
exact way that you wanted it he said
cleanly and clearly and correctly
defined all of that that he may not be
the right messenger on this just because
of the filter it has to get through to
get to reality he's not the right
messenger domestically because of what
political correctness has wrought in our
country but he is absolutely the right
messenger internationally watch the
video of his Riyadh speech don't watch
him watch the fifty-three Muslim Arab
heads of state and their body language
because man did he guys you got a
problem in your mosque in your societies
the extreme is that you have to deal
with it it was tough and you think
they'd be all negative and arms crossed
they were beaming right ceecee abdullah
we're going over finally a guy who
understands our problem and what is
giving us tough love so yeah he is
absolutely the right guy to fix this
internationally which is where it needs
to be fixed
domestically now the political
correctness things better getting away
yeah and the media insanity so do you
think he has more support from foreign
heads of state and then we'll love her
have a sense I mean even at the g8 there
was a feeling of like that actually
these guys kind of liked him oh I can
tell you yeah I told people before the
inauguration you have no idea even if
you voted for him you have no idea how
successful he will be internationally
cuz he's a straight shooter
because he's
an alpha dog and guess what in a lot of
places outside of Berkeley they like of
that right because they know what you're
talking about
they don't have to walk on eggshells
they understand your direction so yeah
internationally our prestige as a nation
has skyrocketed in you know outside of
the European Union and maybe you know
certain Centurion countries exempted
right yeah absolutely so I know we can
do a whole other show on this but but
very quickly just on Russia and
collusion as someone that has been
around the administration you've
mentioned some of these people already
Flynn you know down the road what can
you tell me about that and is there
anything that people should be worried
about or do you think this is all gonna
actually point just back to the
Democrats which every time I see every
time it seems to point to Trump go a
little bit further than he going oh well
wait a minute that was actually the
Democrats my good friend has the best
morning show in DC Chris plumb the radio
host it's actually nationally syndicated
now and I have to credit him with this
he says it's the it's the last scene
from The Hunt for Red October when the
fad captain tupolev launches the the
torpedoes against you know a Sean
Connery on the radio October and it
takes the fuses off and then what
happens remember his XO says you idiot
you've killed us you know the thing
comes back and syncs them yeah I see
this is the the most hilarious boomerang
in history right I'll tell you what the
president told me in the Oval Office
just the two of us it was very
frustrating one day I think maybe jad
had just testified were giving his
speech his little press conference and
he said they will not find anything
because there is nothing and you know
what I take that to the bank there is no
rush of collusion how could there be
after the last 15 months from arming the
Ukrainians to the XL pipeline to Anwar
to finally after 30 years the first
president to ever get NATO to finally
stump up the 2% of GDP that they
promised they'd spend on defense to our
own military expenditure increases every
significant policy decision this
president has taken with regards to
Russia has been
bad for that former KGB colonel so the
idea that we're colluding you have to be
on drugs or be so ideologically blind to
believe that well then what do we do
with this this layer you know whatever
that you you reference deep State before
whatever yeah what do we do with this
think you know even ongoing the the
investigation to me the Mueller
investigation which seems odd to me is
that I don't know what the actual I
don't know that they ever laid out what
their mission is other than to find
crying oh it's a crime right and that
who's right it's a collusion to commit
concerted to can collusion to conspire
in a crime okay but what's the crime
because if it's Russia misrepresenting
itself or perverting the truth on
Facebook
well then Zuckerberg should be right
charged then then you know Anderson
Cooper should be in the doc what are the
charges that have been brought
outrageously ridiculous or lying to
federal investigators you you would
probably be able to be caught in a
perjury trap today okay because not
everybody remembers what they did and
how they did it
perjury traps about what you said to
somebody irrespective of Russia
that's not Donald Trump's problem why a
fraud
eight years ago when manifold worked for
the Ukrainian president what's that got
to do with Russian collusion nothing my
worry is that Muller is not a good actor
if you look at who he's hired it's clear
that there's massive buyers and this
report he's writing for Congress is
simply going to be a political weapon in
the elections and and that's not how
justice is served that's not a rule of
law that's a law enforcement official
getting involved in politics so that's
what I'm concerned about also whether
whether you think something for the
people that are watching us that think
something happened or didn't happen what
I'm more concerned about is that we're
entering this new phase where whether
it's Trump that's president or it's a
Democrat that it's president or it's a
different Republican or whatever that
we're just going to endlessly also have
this layer that all it
does is investigate itself waste money
right you know just constantly just be
keeping us all in this state where we
never know what's real because if you
listen to half of the pundits on
television I mean their implication is
that Russia has installed our president
and in which case that's probably the
single biggest act of war in the history
of the world and what are you actually
saying do we take Trump out and then do
you take out pence and now should Paul
Ryan if you take it to its logical
conclusion oh do we have Paul Ryan is
what are you all resident then and right
where are you really taking this and
that's what I'm worried about is that
we're just gonna end up in this constant
state where yes we'll have a Democrat
and then a Republican in order but will
really be caught in just all government
can do is investigate itself
yeah only more than anything else I see
myself as an optimist but you're giving
me a real challenge what I see myself as
an optimist - yeah I think I'm I'm a
realist so for months and months and
months I refused to use the phrase deep
state I really thought that was a you
know tinfoil hat II kind of thing yeah
for the record I don't even know that
I've even said it once on this show it
sort of pops up an answer okay I use it
now because I've seen it I've seen it
inside the administration when you go to
enough National Security Council
meetings that are classified that is the
the the pinnacle of policymaking in
America outside of the Oval Office and
this is where policies made everybody's
in the room from the NSC then you've got
the outstations on secure BTC from DIA
tether Joint Chiefs CIA state you name
it right you sit there as a newly
appointed political and you listen for
two hours on a big issue Isis Russia
whatever it is and not one participant
mentions the name of the president or
what he said yesterday in Warsaw or what
his objective is given that specific
issue and you see this happen again and
again and again and you're the guy at
the end of the conversation with a funny
accent he says excuse me ladies and
gentlemen
you do know what the president said
about X yesterday can we actually do
that the deep state is real when you've
got GS 15s and SES is saying well I've
been here for
years I know this guy's gonna be here
for four I know better
that's bad for democracy so it'll be
clear that you don't think it's some
sort of massive underground conspiracy
you think it's just the apparatus it's
just the old Washington apparatus so
that I don't think these people who
think Obama's sitting in a cave
somewhere with a joystick he's lazy
you'd never be a mastermind it's not
specter rights not Blofeld but but no
there's a culture in government that's
antithetical to an undermining that
undermining the president on a daily
basis but but there is there is
concerted effort in the media oh my god
I mean Ben Rhodes brags about AI that
game I can't believe what he says my
buddies the left-wing journalists are
morons and then my echo chamber he built
this machine that was was this
incestuous connection between people in
the West Wing people in a think tank
community and their buddies in the media
I mean look at the attack pieces on
anybody me or whatever it's very
interesting something to do a case study
adrenaline school one attack piece will
drop at 7 a.m. by two o'clock in the
afternoon 30 he'll get written we're
just simply cut and paste but if you
don't know that it looks as though my
gosh coke is a fascist look it's one
guy's article that was written because
Ben Rhodes told them to ride it that
comes and multiplies on the right how do
we react well I got my op-ed
international review this one right
there's a Gulf in terms of managing
narratives the left built built up whole
ecosystem
and we're still in the 1980s you know
Orwell take out a full-page ad in the
washing the ice well that's why we're
discussing right yeah I think it's so
important to not on I think most people
especially just because of the way
social media works they immediately go
to the full-on conspiracy of Obama with
the joystick or just some other vert you
know the globalist thing and this whole
where to me it's like they're there what
you just described seems more realistic
to me that there's an apparatus there
that then is still connected to the idea
that seems we can we can discuss that in
a sensible way with one addition and and
and I appreciate this not having been
you know in the target hairs of the
crosshairs for so long they have an
advantage because our side is predicated
on what David the individual right
manifest destiny the rugged
individualism we believe in the
individual the left by definition is a
collective entity I mean there are
elements of the Borg in the left and it
is a it truly is a collective collective
mob mentality a friend of mine on Murray
if you're watching I mean thank you
there is a smile when one guy goes after
Gawker or Bannen or whoever the
president there's this massive
collective pile on it's not a conspiracy
yeah but it but it's a collect they're
all on the same hymn sheet they don't
need direction
well they say oh yeah let's go after him
which is which puts us on the right at a
disadvantage
yeah so this is just sort of an emerging
group thing it's because of the actual
thing yeah Wow we could do we're gonna
do this again
I hope so this is so much fun yeah this
was an absolute pleasure
for more on dr. Gorka I feel like I have
to say last I know well I would if I'm a
pro when I'm doing that later okay hey
Sebastian but I feel like dr. Gorka I
mean you should be a Star Wars character
it's all over there
for more on sebastian follow him on
twitter it's at Seb Gorka
[Music]
you
[Music]